max
suppose
one has an idea or a couple of ideas uh
related that only
that i am fully equipped to implement
all by myself so i'm a technologist and
i can build it all myself it's a
software-based initial
prototype but the prototype is such that
it would
it would be
you could you could
uh
you know similar to clubhouse in the
sense uh i believe i can build a
prototype of clubhouse i'm not bombs i'm
not really a competitor
uh but
you know my question is can you how far
can you go along
my sense is i would like to go alone as
far as possible and show to the world
there's a compelling prototype is that a
fool's hand
yeah i think that's a great question so
i think there's a related i'm going to
answer the question in a related but
different way which is when you create a
business when you create a product what
are you doing what is what is the point
of leverage what is the most important
thing it's the creativity it's the act
of creating the right thing if you
create the right thing you will find
product market fit and the world will be
the path to your door if you create the
wrong thing you miss if for example if
paul and rohan had spent their time
instead of creating clubhouse they'd
created something just slightly
different that didn't catch then no
amount of hard work they put in would
have mattered no matter how much of a
team that hired would have mattered it's
the it's like that getting that creative
spark right
so what i believe at an early stage a
startup should be optimizing for is
creative execution and that's a weird
combination of doing the right thing and
doing it fast and doing it well so
there's you got to have a number of
iterations you got to be able to take
your creativity and take 10 20 30 50
attempts in quick succession you have to
create them high quality like one of the
things that always impressed me about
clubhouse was not only is it updating
the app a lot not the shipping features
all the time but it's just extremely
well implemented it's almost pixel
perfect someone is obsessing over where
all the features and buttons and links
and so on go
and then there's creativity in terms of
good ideas and the creativity needs
criticism it can't just live on its own
because uh if if we just want to start
forming connections and come with ideas
we can come with them all day long but
someone has to critique them but in the
friendly improv kind of way where they
say yes that's one idea and we can also
do it this way um so it has to be like
positive constructive criticism to go
with it so really the question you're
asking is not how many people do i need
on my team or how big should the company
be or should i prototype my own it's
who are what is the right combination of
people to spark maximum creativity or
maximum creative execution because it's
not just whiteboarding this is execution
so maximum creative execution
historically that turns out to be two
people it's not always the case
sometimes you can have a lot of
creativity with just one person who's
been thinking about the problem for a
long time for example satoshi nakamoto
is probably one person vitalik uh you
know
actually it's not fair i don't want to
say vitalik was single-handed because i
know he did have other people around him
so i don't actually know the founding
story but
there are examples where the creativity
is mainly in one individual and there
are lots of examples where the
creativity is mainly two people riffing
back and forth and improving each
other's ideas and really just
complementing each other well
and then from there it gets rarer and
harder as you add more people so can
your maximum point of creativity be
three people sure it could four less
likely five way less likely by the time
you're 10 your creative your your
execution capabilities have gone way up
but your creative capabilities have gone
way down so i actually think what you
want to figure out is
what is your creative execution
capability if you're a one-person
machine if you can crank out lots and
lots of iteration you have lots of good
ideas you've thought about the problem
deeply those ideas have been better over
the years and you have a strong vision
then just recruiting a person for the
sake of recruiting them odds are it's
going to make you less creative you're
going to spend a lot of time trying to
explain things to that person you might
clash but on the other hand if you had
like say an office mate or a former
business partner or a grad student that
you'd work with you get along great you
both like riff on each other's ideas
that person does something you can't do
well and you do something they can't do
well
and the two of you together enjoy
working back to back then that team is
going to have much better creative
execution than you can have on your own
so i would i would optimize for creative
execution
and only you can answer that question
because only you know who's around you
and what you're capable of
brilliant thank you
[Music]
so
[Music]
you